SO WE GET UNDERWAY ON A
SHARKS KEEPING  IT INAFSSON KEE
LOOK AT THIS TOUGH TURNOVOV
IF COMES TO CENTER AND
BROKEN UP BY SAN JOSE.
SABRES TRY TO KEEP IT IN AND THA
LONG SHOT THAT GETS OFF A
NOW.
IN OVER THE LI OF
HIS STICK, RJ, TALKING TO HIM
COMING OFF STEERED ACROSS ICE T
ASPLUND.
STEERED ON THE WING ANDFRONT.
THE
BATTLE, GETS STRIPPED OF THE
TAPPED AHEAD BY HERTL OH,
TAKES A QUICK BACK TO THE
POINT.
SHOT THAT MISSES.THERE, AFTER MW
THEY SCORE.
AND BUFFALO CAUGHT UP ICE AGAIN
THROUGH TO THE
NET.
BUTCHER'S GOT IT AGAIN.
RIGHT T T AIR TO
CENTER ICE AND KNOCKED DOWND FO.
>> Rob: YEAH, THEY HAVEN'T DONE.
BUT IT'S BROKEN UP ONE-ON-ONE.
HE'S GOT THE WHOLE NET AND HE
RUSHES IF. COZENS.
THERE IT IS.
COZENS GOING TO FEET HINOSTROZA.
HINOSTROZA'S GOING TO THROW IT
SCOOOORE!
JEFF SKINNER FININ
WHAT A SHOT FAR SIDE, JUST INTO
THE CORNER, CROSS SEGMENT.
>> Rick: I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW, I
WA IT LOW, THAT'S
THEIR IN BEHIND HERE.
LOOK AT THIS.
HAYDEN DOES NICEE
AND THEY SCOOOORE!
ATON.
THOMPSON JAMMED IT BACK INTO THE
CORNER.